By providing the smart connection to
the rest of the world while respecting
the user's attention,
Android Wear feels personal and global.
It's simple and smart, and
it's unobtrusive and ever-ready.
Now applications that represent
the following principles
will feel most at home in
the overall Android Wear experience.
Wearable apps are aware of
the user's context, their time,
location, and physical activity.
Now the apps use this information
to insert cards into the stream
when they become relevant.
This makes Android Wear timely,
relevant, and very specific.
A classic wristwatch is designed to let
you see the time in a split second and
get on with what you were doing.
And it should be the same for
Android Wear.
The less time it takes to use your
software, the more time the user can be
present in whatever they're doing,
and the more overall value they get.
Android wear is fast,
sharp, and immediate.
Remember what we looked
at just a moment ago.
The wearable can talk to the user, and
the user can ask things of the wearable.
Now you can visualize this much
like a personal assistant.
It knows you and your preferences.
It'll only interrupts you when
absolutely necessary, and
it's always on hand to
provide a ready answer.
Android Wear is helpful,
it's respectful, and it's responsive.
Android Wear focuses on
simple interactions,
only requiring input by the user
when absolutely necessary.
Most inputs are based around
touch swipes and voice.
And inputs requiring fine-grained
finger movements are to be avoided.
The Android Wear is gestural,
simple, and fast.
Now keep these in mind as you dream
up your Android Wear experience.
As with everything here,
please also check out the additional
detail in our documentation.